at just 33 years old Taylor Swift has
become a billionaire with an estimated
net worth of $1.1
billion Taylor Swift's eras tour started
out as a retrospective of her nearly two
decade career and a celebration of her
10 iconic albums it has become an
unprecedented Financial phenomenon that
has already grossed 780 million in
ticket sales on its way to becoming the
top earning tour of all time she is now
the first musician to make the
billionaire ranks solely based on her
songs and performances according to
Forbes she pocketed an estimated $190
million after taxes from the first leg
of her era's tour and another $35
million from the first two weeks of
screenings of Taylor Swift the era's
tour movie another $500 million is based
on the rising value of her music catalog
and she has another $125 million in real
estate and a $10 million private plane
Swift's rise comes amid a boom for
celebrity billionaires but unlike her
Superstar colleagues Swift doesn't have
a profitable side hustle boosting her
net worth like Jay-Z Rihanna and Jimmy
Buffett that puts Swift in a class with
Legends like Bruce Springsteen whose
lifetime pre-tax earnings are over $1
billion the majority of which was earned
on the road touring Forbes estimates the
value of Swift's catalog to be worth
roughly $500 million her master's
recordings her first six albums were
famously scooped up in 2019 by Scooter
Braun and later sold to Shamrock capital
for $300 million which Swift claims was
done behind her back the pop singer
famously took back control of her music
when following a bitter public dispute
Swift got her Revenge by signing a
lucrative distribution deal with
universal music group that gave her
complete ownership and full economic
interest in both the songwriting and the
recordings she has since released four
new albums and re-recorded versions of
four albums that were part of the
Shamrock sale including 1989 Taylor's
version that was released at midnight on
Friday since she released her 2019 album
lover her first under her deal with umg
her Us album sales inclusive of track
sale and streaming equivalents have
totaled $ 37.3 million according to data
provided to Forbes by Luminate and
according to sound royalties her six
album Master catalog at bmlg was valued
at $140 Million by Braun's Team 5 years
ago because Swift wrote nearly all of
her top 50 Billboard Chart hits that
boosts her share of the publishing pot
significantly this has been the most
extraordinary experience of my entire
life said Taylor regarding her ays tour
her Newfound billionaire status proves
just how extraordinary it truly
was